>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Nicholas A. Brown:
Good afternoon everyone.
Welcome to the Library of Congress
and to the Pickford Theater.
My name is Nick Brown, I am in
the office of special events
and public programs here at the
library, and also a past chair
of LC Globe, which is the library's
LGBTQ employee association.
Very pleased to be here with you
today, and also David France,
my colleague Lisa and
also my colleague Meg.
Lisa's going to do a
formal intro in a moment.
But I just wanted to give you some
updates on housekeeping things
and also some event announcements.
The program today is being
filmed for future webcast.
So, that will be up on the
library's website in a few months
and on the YouTube Channel.
So, when we get to Q&A
ask questions accordingly
for the permanence of the archive.
And then, visit us at
LOC.gov/lgbt to learn
about the library's resources
relating to the topics
that we're covering today.
If you didn't attend the pop-up
exhibit in June, it was remarkable
and we had several sections that
addressed HIV/AIDS and culture.
And the bibliography
from the exhibit is up
and available on the website.
If you're into film, we have
a bunch of events coming
up that you would be
interested in attending.
First off, this Friday night
we're having the creators
of "The Blair Witch Project" here
in the Coolidge Auditorium to talk
about making modern ghost stories.
It's kind of like high-end
fake news kind
of thing, which his interesting.
And there will be a screening of
the film immediately following
in the Coolidge Auditorium.
And then, on Saturday afternoon at 4
o'clock, we're going to be screening
"Hocus Pocus" for those that
are more inclined to that.
You're welcomed to attend in
costume for either, but please note
that there are rules about
masks and the police and such.
So, if you plan to come in costume
read the press release first.
Also, the library's new pop-up
exhibit, LOC Halloween Chambers
of Mystery opens this Thursday,
runs through November 1st.
We have an entire room
dedicated to film.
There are silent films
and sound films,
and also there's a radio horror
montage which is pretty cool.
And we have a day of the dead alter
for Frida Kahlo, which is amazing
and would not have
happened in years past.
So, check that out, there's
been a lot of work going
on behind the scenes to get
the pop-up exhibit running.
Stay tuned to Globes
future programming.
You can join our Facebook
group, just type in LC Globe
on Facebook, you'll find us.
And you can also list serve by
contacting Meg, mmet@loc.gov,
or myself at mbrown@loc.gov.
Great, thanks and welcome to Lisa.
>> Lisa Massengale:
Okay, thank you Nick.
I'm Lisa Massengale
from the Science,
Technology and Business Division.
And I'm delighted to welcome David
France today to talk about his book,
"How to Survive a Plague;
The Inside Story
of How Citizens and
Science Tamed AIDS."
And the creator
of the Oscar-nominated
documentary of the same title.
Mr. France has been writing
about the AIDS crisis since 1982,
beginning in gay community papers.
Continued on to "The New York
Times," where he was the,
I've got to look at my notes; the
AIDS news writer in the nineties,
and "Newsweek" where
he was senior editor
for investigations until 2003.
He's also the author of the
critically acclaimed books
"Our Fathers; An Investigation
into the Catholic Church
Sexual Abuse Crisis
and The Confession" a memoire he
co-wrote with the former governor
of New Jersey, Jim McGreevey.
So, please join me in
welcoming David France.
[ Applause ]
>> David France: Thank
you everybody.
I have trouble with my voice today.
So, I'm going to try to
get through this with you.
But I thought we'd start
first with a little selection
from the documentary,
"How to Survive a Plague."
[ Music ]
>> Welcome to Act Up.
We are the AIDS coalition
to unleash power.
A diverse non-partisan group
of individuals united in anger
and committed to direct action to.
>> End the AIDS crisis.
>> Less than 12 hours from now,
we are going to be
taking over city hall.
[ Chanting ]
>> Mr. Mayor, in campaigning
for the lesbian and gay vote
in an election year, a bit of
historical context is necessary
in dealing with the AIDS
crisis in New York City.
It wasn't until 1983
that you met with people
to deal with the AIDS crisis.
How do you respond
to these criticisms?
>> Well, that's a falsehood.
>> Please, anybody who's
thinking about being arrested,
fill out a support sheet, make
sure your support person knows
who you are and what
group you're in.
Yeah?
>> If we end up in the tombs, is
there like, a queer tank there
and would you recommend
that we ask to be there?
>> There is a homo-tank and
I've been there and it's better
than the straight tank,
let me tell you.
>> Who else?
Yes?
>> In the past, you've
described Act Up as fascist,
yet in the press release, you
called them "concerned citizens"
and I was wondering
what changed your mind?
>> Well, I don't think
you can't use both.
Fascists can be concerned citizens.
And I don't believe
they are fascists,
I think they have used
a fascist tactic.
>> Let us celebrate together
tonight, the end of the last day
on which Ed Koch can tell
himself that the communities
which are being decimated
by this epidemic are so weak
and so divided among themselves,
that he can keep serving
us this kind of bullshit.
Tomorrow morning, he will
begin to learn the truth.
[ Applause ]
[ Chanting tomorrow morning at
city hall Act Up, stand tall ]
[ Music ]
>> We're talking to Jim Eigo
from the Treatment Issues
Committee of Act Up.
Jim, what specific treatment
issues are being brought
into this demonstration this week?
The municipal hospitals
are totally falling apart.
More than half of the
people that get diagnosed
with AIDS today get diagnosed in
the emergency rooms of our city.
You're going to find
yourself waiting four days
in an emergency room
before you get a bed.
>> Pretty scared, but
being HIV-positive,
I don't have much choice
in the matter.
I just love all these people,
and I think what we're doing
is really right and I mean,
listen to this and
look at all the people.
It's just really wonderful and
it's worth putting yourself
on the line for.
>> There is no accurate diagnosis.
There are incentives in the city
hospitals not to diagnose people
with AIDS and therefore,
people don't get treated.
We are angry at the way this
city has handled this crisis
and we demand that Ed
Koch exert leadership
and declare a state of emergency.
>> Go in the street now or
wait, those are the options.
One, he says go.
Says now, three, Tom.
>> We're standing here
with Larry Kramer.
What is Act Up trying
to say today to Ed Koch?
>> We're sending a message
to public officials,
to closeted public officials,
that we won't be shat on anymore
and obviously all the AIDS issues.
>> I would love to see like,
more cameras or something,
you know, for our own protection.
>> Did everyone hear his concern?
>> People die every day,
friends get sick every day.
It's like being in the trenches.
There's such anger in the community
and it is coalescing in a way
that has never been done before.
>> Okay, which way do we face
girlfriends, this way or that way?
[ Crowd Noise ]
>> Healthcare is a right,
healthcare is a right.
Healthcare is a right,
Pump up the budget.
healthcare is a right.
Healthcare is a right,
[ Crowd Noise ]
[ Music ]
>> "Compromised" 1982.
On a crisp, fall like afternoon,
Dr. Joseph Sonovand [assumed
spelling] found his way to the back
in a booth at Joe Junior's
a noisy coffee shop
on Sixth Avenue, in the village.
Richard Berkowitz could see
that his doctor was angry.
His temper had a tendency to
further rumple his appearance
and tie his tongue
even more than usual.
Sonovand had been watching the
city's weekly health bulletins
continue to report
pneumocystis pneumonia deaths.
Any trained physician should know
how to prevent such a fate he felt.
"These doctors are not delivering,
they're just windbags," he said.
"Deadheads."
He handed the most recent Department
of Health briefings to Berkowitz.
Berkowitz thumbed through the
papers, not quite understanding.
"NYU has the distinction,"
Sonovand underscored with sarcasm,
"of having the largest
number of patients by virtue
of their advertising and
they're doing nothing.
By keeping those patients, it means
they are keeping them from people
who know what to do to help them."
Berkowitz interjected timidly, his
background was not in medicine.
He was a professional sex worker.
"Like immunologists?"
"Yes. They haven't proven they are
competent to do any of this work.
Who is Dr. Friedman
Keene [assumed spelling]?
He's a society skin
doctor as far as I know.
He's certainly not equipped to
get into this kind of stuff."
Diners from around the surrounding
booths could make out every word.
"These people have lymphadenopathy,
and he's not equipped
to deal with that.
So, they're dealing
with the skin cancer.
They grab up all the patients.
They're killing any number of
patients with chemotherapy."
His eyes narrowed.
"He's a skin doctor."
He was even more venomous about Dr.
Linda Labenstein [assumed spelling].
"Labenstein has got
no experience at all.
She's very young.
She hasn't been out of
medical school for very long.
Why should you go to
person with no experience?
She's fooling around.
They're fooling around.
I would never let any of my
patients go anywhere near NYU."
He shook his head balefully.
"The patient's I've had
there, I've taken away.
One patient, thank goodness, he
went there and he's still alive.
He would've been pumped
full of chemotherapy
and he be quite dead right now.
There's no question about that."
Sonovand didn't have to
be oncologist to know
that people were not doing well
on traditional chemotherapy.
"There are new agents that are
not that devastating," he said.
"Interferon?
" Berkowitz asked.
The grapevine was full
of praise for interferon.
Sonovand shook his head.
His experiments had shown
it offered little hope.
It caused fevers and
inhibited development
of white blood cells,
especially CD4 cells.
The body's elite disease
fighting squadrons.
Interferon's massive proliferation
in people with AIDS appeared
to contribute to the
course of their disease.
Yet, numerous well-meaning
researchers, including those
at the NIH, were injecting
even more interferon
into immune deficiency patients,
believing its antiviral properties
might simultaneously fight whatever
was causing illness.
"I wouldn't let any of my patients
even smell the stuff," he said.
"There's only one treatment that's
rational and that's plasmapheresis."
Plasmapheresis was used for lupus
and other autoimmune diseases
in which the body produces
excessive antibodies,
just as AIDS seemed to be doing.
The procedure removes those
antibodies mechanically
by rerouting blood out one arm
passing it through a centrifuge,
then returning the blood through
the other arm, minus the antibodies.
He had sent his other patient
Michael Callan [assumed spelling]
to Boston for the procedure,
noting that the patient felt
much less fatigued afterwards.
"It's relatively harmless,"
Sonovand said.
Still most other doctors were
not offering plasmapheresis
and some had openly criticized
him for championing it.
"In other words, it
cleans your blood?"
"Yes," he snapped impatiently.
Then more tentatively,
"it might've saved lives."
Berkowitz looked up from his food.
"If a person has the immune
deficiency, but doesn't have any
of the debilitating diseases,"
he wondered, describing himself;
"what do you think the chances are
that the immune deficiency
could reverse itself."
Sonovand answered carefully,
"I think if you get
plasmapheresised it might help.
You would be a candidate,
for example.
I'd like to get you
plasmapheresised to see
if we could reverse
your parameters."
Berkowitz was numbed
by the recommendation.
He thought that his
parameters, though cockeyed,
didn't merit dramatic intervention.
Since having his gland biopsied,
he'd gone totally celibate
to protect against any new
challenges to his immune system.
Consequently, he was
also off cocaine.
In the world of sex work, they went
together like tea and crumpets.
Only cigarettes and marijuana
remained in his regular routine,
though in dramatically
reduced quantities.
He was eating better, sleeping
better, showing his body respect.
He had hoped that this alone
would allow his body to heal
from the dual infections of
cytomegalovirus and hepatitis A,
which Sonovand had
diagnosed over the summer.
Obviously, his doctor
was less patient.
"There was a plasmapheresis center
in New York," Sonovand said,
"but the director there had
so far refused AIDS patients.
I have to call Bruce Gordon and
beg him to do you," Sonovand said,
adding another item to his
impossibly long agenda, he sighed.
"It's being denied people
because these doctors,
these great experts" he
didn't finish the sentence.
Waiting for the waiter's
attention, he looked exhausted.
"I've got to get back
to the office."
They sat in silence
waiting for the check.
After a time, Sonovand tilted
his head toward a tape recorder
that Berkowitz had brought with him.
"All this is happening, there
really is no one of substance
to chronicle this, the
tragedy of all this.
A person who knows how to write,
who knows people, where
is such a person.
This is New York City and
nobody's chronicling this?"
If he was asking Berkowitz
to create a record,
he didn't say so directly,
nor did he have to.
That fall, Michael Callan spent
$39 on a recorder of his own
and joined Berkowitz in taping
new Sonovand disquisitions.
By now, researchers had starting
using a new name for grid,
answering the question
about the concerns
about naming a disease
after the community.
There was nothing gay
about collapsed immunity,
as Sonovand put it.
The disease was rebranded as
Acquired Immune Deficiency Syndrome,
but the new name didn't
change perspective.
In the guise of AIDS rage
across the country came wave
after wave of anti-gay violence.
Just as Sonovand had prophesied.
Callan and Berkowitz
taped Sonovand over lunch,
when he met with the researchers
and during late night phone calls,
which had become commonplace.
Cassettes piled up
in both apartments
where they were reviewed
and swapped.
They had become Sonovand's unpaid
amanuensis and self-styled acolytes;
standing in the spillway
of his developing thoughts,
so that others might benefit.
"I got it on tape," Berkowitz
would announce, "if you forget."
"Paranoid fantasies," 1984.
The summer of 1984 saw a fulcrum
of disease in the gay ghetto.
At St. Vincent's emergency room
was visible behind enormous windows
on the corner of West 11th
Street and Seventh Avenue.
Before the crisis exploded,
how many hundreds
of times had I walked
past those windows,
oblivious to the small
kabuki dramas enacted there.
Now, I find myself choked with
panic anytime I came here.
One sticky afternoon, I slowed
to measure the epidemic
through the plate glass.
Praying to see only strangers.
Three-quarters of the
seats were filled.
Scanning the rows, I could see every
third or fourth man had the look.
Sunken cheeks, sparse hair,
eyes that showed fear.
Shoulders that bent in pain.
One, all spots and
bones, balanced painfully
on a pillow he brought
along from home.
Another seems to be dozing.
His head was cocked backward onto
a companion's arm and his mouth
and his eyes were both wide open.
The blind, like horses
and snakes don't need
to close their eyes to sleep.
A cab pulled up beside me, a
healthy man first out the door,
bent to carefully extract this
frail companion from the back seat,
and operation as ordered
and precise as origami.
I held open the hospital
door and blinkered
by their mission they picked
past me without a nod.
They were no older than I was.
I remained on the sidewalk
for a long time watching them
navigate the admissions process
and settle into bucket
seats to await their turn.
The healthy partner
whispering nonstop
into his lover's nodding
and sweaty head.
That was my experience
with early AIDS.
I stood on the sidewalk
of the plague,
grateful to not enter its tower.
In San Francisco, Bobby
Campbell and his message
of patient empowerment were in great
demand leading to urgent invitations
for him to address people with
AIDS in New York, Miami, Atlanta,
Washington, Seattle,
Dallas, and Los Angeles.
He appeared on "Nightline,"
the late-night ABC news program
and on Phil Donahue's show.
On June 28, he was in New York to
give one of his inspirational talks
and to attend the 15th annual Gay
Pride March, reuniting with people
with AIDS leaders from
around the nation.
On that weekend, he fulfilled his
biggest dream formally incorporating
The National Association of People
with AIDS to further the work
that they'd begun the
year before in Denver.
Campbell returned home in time for
the Democratic Ntional Convention,
which opened in San
Francisco on July 15.
On a gusty afternoon,
he stood on a stage
across from the Muskogee Center
with his lover at his side,
delivering a well-paced
and strident keynote speech
to 100,000 protesters.
He looked frail and tired, but
his connection to the crowd
that day was electric
and his voice was strong,
echoing across the sea of heads.
"I have a message for
the nation," he said.
"Very often lesbians and gay men
are portrayed as isolated, alienated
and alone, or in a pathetic
search for desperate sexuality.
I don't think that
that's true about us.
I think it is important for
people to understand that lesbians
and gay men do not exist
outside of a context.
We exist in the context
of the people we love
and those that love us."
The crowd roared as he kissed
his lover on the forehand.
"I the message for the person with
AIDS who may be in Des Moines,
or Indianapolis, or in
Queens, or anywhere.
Keep the faith, baby.
I love you."
Campbell cemented his place as
the preeminent infected militant
that day, but his whirlwind
efforts took a toll on him.
A few days later, a nasty case
of shingles engulfed his head,
leaving behind a field
of deep scars.
And in a few weeks, he entered the
hospital with a brainstem overrun
with cryptococcal meningitis.
A horrifyingly painful experience.
When the news reached New
York City, Michael Callan,
bought a card to cheer him up with
a photo of the performer, Divine,
in a nurse's uniform
menacingly hoisting an enema bag.
"How many of this card
have you gotten?
It's just so you."
He wrote. "Get well,
that's an order."
But Campbell never saw the card.
Bob Hilliard, his lover
watched helplessly
as the blood pressure monitor fell
from 100 to 50 and then 40 than 0.
Instinctively he allowed
the medical staff space
for gently removing all the
hoses and pipes and devices
from Campbell spent body.
At precisely noon on August
15, 1984, a month to the day
after his memorable last address,
Campbell ended his battle.
He was 32 years old.
News of the death spread
quickly through San Francisco.
It wasn't long before someone
at the Badlands Bar took the
big chalk stick and wrote
on the blackboard, "love
after death for Bobby."
Knowing how devastated
community would be,
the city shut down
Christopher Street
for his funeral cortege
two days later.
Hundreds of bereaved men and women
arrived through the dusking light,
followed by hundreds more.
Soon, a sea of grief stretched
down the hill past the
famous Castro Theater
into the next intersection
and beyond.
A thousand people standing
hushed in Bobby Campbell's honor.
Whether through his work as a
nurse, or a tireless AIDS advocate,
his leadership had touched the
community like nobody else's.
The eulogies were stridently
political.
Holly Near and Lea
Delaria sang tributes.
A bit of footage from
Campbell's recent speech flickered
on a large screen over the stage.
Momentarily returning him
to his beloved people.
"I have a message for the
lesbian and Gay community,"
he was saying, as if from beyond.
"it's important to understand
that sex does not cause disease.
Homosexuality does
not cause disease.
Germs do. Learn and
practice safe sex.
The throne on Castro Street
nodded silently to his manifesto,
but then the voice of
Campbell added something
that they had trouble accepting.
"It's important for us
to learn about AIDS,"
he said, "but not to panic.
There's no reason to
become hysterical."
At that moment, it seemed that
there was ample reason for hysteria.
The bad news was piling on.
A new study from DC, in which
healthy appearing gay men were
screened for signs
of viral infection,
showed a prevalence
rate of 60 to 70%.
Men just like those filling
the street at the Castro.
Using conservative estimates of the
number of gay men in the country,
that meant that 8 million
were marked for death just
as cutting as Campbell's.
The cataclysm awaited the community.
About a week after his
massive memorial service,
which failed to garner coverage
in the East Coast press,
a large envelope from Bob
Hilliard arrived at the offices
of the New York native,
where he worked
as a reporter and typesetter inside.
Inside, he'd written a note, "Bobby
Campbell, died yesterday, August 15,
of AIDS-related meningitis in
San Francisco General Hospital."
This was how we received
the awful news.
In the course of my reporting,
I had spoken to Campbell
on the telephone, but we never met.
Reading Hilliard's
note, I wept angrily.
Hilliard went on to say,
the enclosed was found among
his papers stamped and sealed.
It seems clear to us that Bobby
intended the letter to be sent.
So, we are forwarding it
to you for publication.
Thank you for complying with
what surely was his final wish.
I carefully smoothed Campbell's
last communiqué onto my desktop.
It was not a farewell,
and carried no hint
of the opportunistic infection that
would sneak up on him so violently.
Instead, it was a letter to the
editor, addressed to an article
that I ran about the
bathhouse controversies.
In his quiet voice, and
gentle optimism he warned
against moral absolutism
on either side.
"AIDS partisans are
not either traders,
or murderers, or heroes," he said.
My hands trembled as I sat at
the enormous photo offset machine
and put his last public words
into crisp columns of text.
That December, Lester
Kinsaulding [assumed spelling]
in his late middle years,
took his usual chair
at the White House Briefing
Room just afternoon he rose
with a question.
The president's spokesman
an agile and sandy haired,
Mississippian named Larry
Speaks eyed him playfully.
"Lester's beginning to
circle now," he said,
as though he were narrating
a sporting event.
He's moving in front."
Kinsaulding was more of a
gadfly than a journalist,
a self-syndicated columnist known
for wearing an ecclesiastical
collar to briefings.
He had been ordained once
in the Episcopal Church.
And issuing challenges from
Reagan's rightmost flank.
Sometimes his questions were just
plain kooky, like the time, perhaps,
moved by a tune stuck in
his head, he wondered,
what does the president
think about muskrat love.
Other reporters christened
him 'the mad monk'
and 'the price we pay
for democracy.'
Few took him seriously.
For Speaks, Kinsaulding's
intercessions were always occasions
for merriment.
"Go ahead," he said cheerfully.
Kinsaulding launched into one
of his customary dispositions.
"Since the Centers for Disease
Control in Atlanta reports
that an estimated," an explosion
of laughter cut him off.
The regulars knew what
was coming next.
So, did Speaks.
"This is going to be
an AIDS question."
The spokesman beamed.
Kinsaulding had raised
the subject before.
Once in October 1982,
and once in June 1983.
The only two times AIDS was
ever mentioned in that room.
Each time was the same;
guffaws and dismissal.
These were the only times the
subject had arisen in connection
with the administration in any way.
Which remained silent
on the disease.
"You were close."
Speaks ribbed him.
"You're close."
"Well, look, can I just
ask my question Larry?"
Kinsaulding's poker face broke.
He wanted a serious
answer this time.
"An estimated 300,000 people
have been exposed to AIDS,
which can be transmitted
through saliva."
He said. That last part was
never true, but his concern was
that people with the disease,
members of what he called the
sodomy lobby were endangering
American life.
"Will the president,
as commander-in-chief,
take steps to protect Armed
Forces, food and medical services
from AIDS patients, and those who
run the risk of spreading AIDS
in the same manner that they
forbid typhoid fever people
from being involved in
health or food services."
Speaks regarded him warmly.
"I don't know."
He said. More laughter.
"Is the president concerned
about the subject, Larry,
that seems to have been evoking
so much jocular reaction here?"
"I haven't heard him
express concern."
Speaks winked.
Gales of laughter followed.
Everyone knew that only
homosexuals concern themselves
with the epidemic.
It was beyond the pale to imagine
the president talking about it.
Chatter flew around the briefing
room as other reporters piped in.
"Has he sworn off water faucets?
It isn't just jocks now, Lester?"
"Lester," said Speaks.
"I have not heard him
express anything on it.
Sorry, but I must confess, I
haven't asked him about it either."
A year ago he had responded
to Kinsaulding's question
by "acknowledging your
interest in the subject."
A year before that he had
parried, I don't have it.
Do you?" With 7699 reported
cases, and 3665 Americans dead,
Kinsaulding was no longer
satisfied with jokes.
"You mean that he's expressed
no opinion about the epidemic?"
He persisted, "Would you
ask him, Larry, would you?"
To which Larry replied,
"Have you been checked?"
Reporters fell out of their seats.
The press conference was
over, that joke always worked.
1986, in the East Village, where
I shared a rundown apartment
on Avenue C, the scene was grim.
Every building was a
microcosm of the plague.
Two floors above in our building,
a slender redhead from Georgia.
In his early 20s fell into a drunken
tailspin following his diagnosis.
For the several weeks before
his family came to collect him,
he lamented his fate
operatically in our living room,
incapable of steeling
himself for the coming battle.
At a time when examples
of surprising grace
and fortitude dominated,
his reaction, however,
understandable, stood out.
His sobbing was a tropical squall.
We never heard from him again.
Across the hall, Evelyn exiled
her husband after a bout
of pneumonia won him
a month in a hospital
and in a discharge
slip that said AIDS.
When he tried to return home,
she met him in the hallway
with the scorching rage
over his admitted drug use,
and as their two young
daughters screamed in confusion,
she issued final banishment orders.
Day after day he returned
seeking forgiveness.
She was too panicked about
her own future to grant.
One morning I found that he had made
a nest for himself in the hallway
between the doors, heartbroken
and desiccated as close
to the girls as he was allowed.
"Are you all right, Juan?"
I asked. "Can I get you anything?"
I had to lean in close
to hear his reply.
"My bones hurt."
He whispered, shifting painfully
from one emaciated hip to another.
He pinched at his yellow
bedroll, unable to turn it
into the cushion that he longed for.
His voice was hallow and raspy.
The unmistaken sound of PCP.
"Do you have a doctor?
Anyone I can call?"
He shook his head.
"The VA, they told me to go
home to Puerto Rico to die.
But how?" He stared at
the door keeping him
from all of his resources.
A sudden pain contorted his face, he
gripped his abdomen and gave a look
of terrified foreknowledge,
but there was no time.
His bowels emptied in a
terrible force painting a mandala
of excrement on the
floor where he sat.
"Let me get you some help,"
I said, reaching around him.
I pounded urgently on the
door of his old apartment.
"No, no, no," he cried
out of embarrassment.
He whispered an incantation
in Spanish meant
to spare his daughters the
site of their father like this.
He managed to get to his feet,
stroking the hallway clean
with his bedding and on
fragile legs carried his shamed
down the stairs to the street.
He need not have fled, his
wife never came to the door.
I'm going to read forward
just a little bit.
My own personal narrative had
me leaving New York to go work
as a journalist in Central
America during the wars there.
I felt the need to cover
someone else's war for a time.
Letters from friends reached me in
the war zones of Central America.
Sometimes weeks in transit
undermining my efforts
to escape the epidemic.
JT, Roger, Michael E., Richard
they'd all dropped dead.
I started keeping a book
with each name and bits
of our last conversations
or intimacies.
Attaching a few sentences like
buoys to memories of them.
JT, young, charming, irresponsible.
Was sleeping on friends
couches at the very end.
Roger, a filmmaker, dead at 40, on
the cusp of a very powerful career.
Richard was the husband of Susan,
our building superintendent,
a bisexual it turns out.
Michael E. had climbed from
poverty to medical school,
and had only begun to practice
when he became a patient instead.
Remembering his heartbreaking 30th
birthday party turned my stomach.
His mother, fulfilling an
old promise had come north
for the first time to cook him
his favorite Southern fare.
But before the guests arrived,
he had told her that he was gay
and that all the guests
would be gay.
This gave her more of a
shock than she could handle.
Already unsteady at the
beginning of the evening,
her wobble grew more pronounced each
time she returned from the corner
in the kitchen where
the bar was set up.
Before the meal was fully plated,
she slid to the floor unconscious.
I helped Michael lift her into bed.
"Are you one too?"
She asked me before
beginning to snore.
"And that was the easy
part," Michael said.
"In the morning, we'll
talk about AIDS."
I'd heard once from Brian Guejuan
[assumed spelling] my old roommate,
his letter was full of exciting
updates about his artwork,
about life in Chicago,
about his lover, Dough,
whom he had nicknamed Buster.
He seemed in good spirits
despite the frank last paragraph.
"My Frankenstein knobs are bigger,
big, hard buttons on my neck.
But at least they don't hurt."
He wrote. "I've had a couple of
other weird health things, thrush,
which is like a gross
blanket in my throat,
and shingles, which hurt like hell.
Obviously, something's gone haywire
but the doctor doesn't know what."
He wasn't letting it get him down.
"I mean, it's been three
years and I'm basically fine."
He insisted.
He didn't mention whether he'd
been tested, and he seemed content,
determined actually to exist
in a state of unknowing.
I didn't address the subject in my
return note, concentrating instead
on lavish descriptions
of life in the jungle.
In our contortions, we were as
purposeful as Tolstoy's amputee
who told a judge how
he coped with the pain.
"The main thing, your honor is not
to spend too much time
thinking about it.
If you don't think about
it, it doesn't seem much."
When the thinking cannot be
vanquished, it drowned out all else.
Sitting on the curb outside my
Managua hotel room one night,
sharing a beer with a friend, I
traced a finger absentmindedly
above the waistband of my jeans
and on my hip I came upon a
spot raised in letters [chime].
That was scary [laughter].
Quickly excusing myself
and returning to my room,
I tore off my clothes and stood
before a bare bulb staring
at the dreaded stigmata.
It made sense.
I had had the battle with
shingles those three years ago.
Countless nights in the
jungle, I woke drenched in sweat
and convinced myself that it was
from tropical heat, nothing else.
The KS had gotten me.
I never mentioned my
lesion to anyone.
And I immediately began
planning to return to New York
to face this new reality.
For a number of frustrating
reasons, this took many, many weeks.
Before departing, I was
overtaken by dysentery
of a dreadfully familiar kind.
The cramping, the inability
to control my bowels,
I had no appetite.
Weight slid off of me.
It could be anything of course, in
this country of non-potable water,
mosquito clouds and casual hygiene.
During the time that I was embedded
with soldiers we had no ready rolls
of paper for cleaning ourselves.
No barracks for washing ourselves.
We had no kitchen for
scouring the pots.
And no silverware at all.
Just shallow plastic bowls we
rotated in a complex choreography,
scooping the gruel to our mouths
with hands as dirty as dirt.
In Managua, I consulted a succession
of well-meaning doctors who admitted
that they had no drugs to
prescribe, and little in the way
of diagnostic tools
given the tight embargoes
of the Reagan administration.
Nobody suspected HIV.
There wasn't a diagnosed
case in the country yet
and since gays they were rounded up
and thrown into a special prison,
out of caution, I didn't
bring it up.
Finally, I presented myself
to a private hospital.
I'd heard rumors that
inpatients were given priority
to access to the armamentarium.
There, I received the presumptive
diagnosis of amoeba infection.
A rampant assault requiring
daily shots
of a viscous remedy into my buttock.
After two weeks, they sent me
back to my hotel with a supply
of loaded needles to
finish the course.
I proved an unskilled
self-administrator.
A friend visiting from New
York didn't mind helping out,
though he proved even less adept.
On his first effort, he
discharged the needle
to shallowly creating a
painful blister in the epidermis
that slowly receded into
a permanent purple scar
that took a shape eerily
of a crucifix.
This all did little
to slow my symptoms.
When I stepped on a scale,
I found I had lost 30 pounds
since leaving New York.
Luckily, my ticket home soon
came and I returned to the city
and to modern medicine, such as was.
It was winter, a year
away I was astounded
to see the stark visual
presence of plague
on the sidewalks below 14th
Street, having the same harrowed,
trembling appearance,
I fitted right in.
Dr. Wakavitcz [assumed
spelling] squeezed me
into her packed schedule.
I stood before her, naked as she
drew her warm hands along my body
to look for knobs on my lymph nodes.
She found none.
She studied the lesion on
my hip with a hurried smile.
It was a type of mole, she
said, nothing to worry about.
But my bony appearance, and
abdominal distress stumped her.
She sent me to a clinic
specializing in tropical diseases
where they diagnosed a spectrum of
bacterial and protozoan infections.
They prescribed Flagyl,
a powerful antibiotics
so punishing it put blood in
my stool, numbed my fingers
and seemed to compress my brain.
Officially, the National Toxicology
Program reasonably anticipated
that Flagyl was carcinogenic,
but it served its purpose
and it put me on the mend.
Despite the fact that I had begun
gaining weight, Dr. Wakavitcz wanted
to see me for a follow
up appointment.
She ran down a list of questions
about possible exposures
and indicators of infection.
My answers all fell
in the safe column,
until she asked about shingles.
I hadn't thought to tell
her about that before.
It hadn't left any scars
and it never returned.
"It can mean a compromised
immune system."
She said, which I knew.
But, she hastily added
"Sometimes, not always.
Sometimes.
Simple stress can bring it on.
Sometimes there's no
triggers at all."
She said. "But I'd like you
to consider an HIV test."
Reluctantly, I agreed.
Reasoning that a positive
diagnosis would do no more harm
to me psychologically than not
knowing, which was consuming me.
It was by now possible to send blood
to commercial labs for testing,
but the risk was still too great.
Insurance companies were dropping
patients who tested positive.
Labs were reporting positive
results to the Department of Health.
The potential for serious
revocations was real.
So, Wakavitcz recommended
using the network
of alternative confidential
testing sites
that had been set up by the CDC.
After drawing my blood, she filled
out a form assigning an untraceable
code number to the sample.
Referenced only inside
her medical files.
Then she handed me the
form and the deep red tube.
"Carry this to the Health
Department on First Avenue."
She said. "There's a
drop off in the lobby.
Don't sign the visitor's
log, just tell them
that you're dropping off a sample."
I did as she said.
At 455 First Avenue,
I passed through a set
of glass doors, fogged by neglect.
The lobby was grimy
and nearly empty,
but for an old gray metal desk
on which a uniformed
guard rested a lazy elbow.
I showed the red of my
vial and without a word,
he pointed to an alcove
beside the elevator bank.
Standing there was a
simple white refrigerator.
The kind you'd expect to
see in a suburban kitchen.
Opening the door suspiciously
I found nothing inside
but a cardboard basket holding
more of what I had brought,
tubes of blood with confidential
identifiers rubber banded to them.
I placed mine on the top of the
pile, praying that the next person
to open the cooler, didn't
perversely scramble the vials
and the forms, giving me
someone else's diagnosis.
I waited two sleepless
weeks for the results.
When it was time, I returned to
the doctor's office for my results.
They were negative.
I was so relieved,
I nearly collapsed.
"But don't live your life any
differently," the doctor said.
"This could be a false negative.
Or, there could be an incubation
period, we just don't know.
And anyway," she said, gesturing
to the fishbowl of condoms
on the receptionists counter,
"everybody else is positive,
so the old rules still apply."
How to survive a plague."
[ Applause ]
Hi. Any questions?
Comments?
[ Inaudible Audience Comment ]
So, the book talks about the kind
of disorientation that took place
in 1996 when effective
medicine was finally available.
When the plague went from an
almost certain death sentence
to a survivable infection.
And that was a confusing time
for everybody in the movement.
And certainly, in the community
that was afflicted by HIV.
Nobody knew how long it would last.
And then when it lasted, no
one knew what to do next.
The plague years lasted 15 years.
And for anybody who was on the front
line, that was all that we did.
And a lot of people left that time
ill-prepared to do anything else.
Activism lost a lot of its urgency
and especially from those people
who were in activism to
save their own lives.
And once they saved their own
lives, they achieved this thing
that they never thought
they would get to.
They turned to trying to figure
out what their lives would be.
And all the money for AIDS ended.
And you know, I continued on as an
AIDS journalist, I was lucky enough
to have been able to find a
way to move my AIDS activism
into the future, but I found
that it was harder and harder
to get stories published.
I was explaining earlier, that the
reason I did the documentary before
the book was because I could
get nobody to publish that.
Nobody would publish
a book about AIDS.
Because it had already been told
and we'd already been through it
and nobody wanted to hear it
anymore, and the was so much death.
And, so we all went quiet.
Activism did continue.
Many of the people who
were front-line activists
in the plague years, especially
those who were working on treatment,
turned their attention
to accessing treatment.
And they moved to Africa many,
and helped establish the movements
there for treatment access.
And that was very slow going, but in
recent years it's been phenomenal,
you know, at the end of the
film which came out in 2012,
and the film is all about the
discovery, the interaction.
And the book is between these
activists, and patients,
and researchers that
brought about the drugs.
It says that 6 million people
are alive thanks to these drugs
that were discovered in that way.
Well, that was 5 years ago,
now 20 million people are
living on those drugs.
So, that activism is
pushing those prices down
and building those
networks and giving people
across the globe access
to healthcare,
sometimes for the first time.
So, that has worked.
What hasn't worked is any
significant slowing in the country,
even, of the transmissions.
And HIV rates have been at about
50,000 a year in the US in 1996.
And they were 50,000 a year in 2012.
And until the last two years there
had been really no significant
change in that number.
And it's finally starting
to come down now.
But, you know, one of the things
that activists lost
access to is money.
People had spent a fortune
on empowering the movement
and creating the institutions
around AIDS.
And they were depleted.
And wanted to do something
else with their money.
So, we lost a lot of traction I
think on many different levels.
>> Speaker 1: Well, I think
it's a different population now.
It's a different population that
is contracting AIDS, is that fair?
>> David France: It's largely poor,
largely southern, largely of people
of color, mostly African-American
kids.
The largest demographic group is gay
kids in the South, ages 14 to 20.
And we just haven't reached them.
And you're right, it's moved
out of cities for the most part,
and it's moved into parts of America
that our national media
doesn't reach or go to.
And in too many instances,
our hearts don't reach either.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
Such a good question.
I write a lot about AZT in the book.
The AZT was the first drug
of course that came out.
It held incredible promise in the
hearts and minds of so many people.
It turned out, in the long run,
although it dominated the
drug market for many years,
it did nothing to extend life.
It really made, [inaudible]
very rich,
but it did not have any
kind of desired impact.
However, in 1996, when
the new drug compound,
the protease inhibitors
were brought to market,
they also didn't work very well
on their own and only worked
in combination with
two other drug classes.
And one of those drugs was AZT.
So, AZT finally did work in '96.
And was still being prescribed
up until just a few years ago.
So, it did life up to its
promise, but it took a long time.
In the cocktail, right,
that three drug cocktail
that proved so miraculous.
And what a miracle, right?
You know, it emptied hospitals.
People just got up.
People who had no expectations
to ever leave
that hospital, walked out.
Yeah, yeah way too late.
And I think the point and the
reason I wanted to go back
to this history was, it wouldn't
have happened even in '96,
I'm certain, if it
weren't for AIDS activism.
And if AIDS activism
had started earlier,
fi the rage in the community
had taken hold earlier,
it may have happened earlier.
It certainly would have happened,
I think science would
have solved the problem.
But the reforms that were
put in place, and the urgency
that was brought to bear on the race
for this drug is owed specifically
to the people I focus on
in the film and the book.
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
Oh, I wasn't.
No, not at all.
I was saying were it not for
them, and the work that they did,
we wouldn't have gotten
the drugs in 1996.
Maybe, 1998, or maybe 2000.
But not then at all, so
I think you're right.
Yes, question?
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
Well, I certainly see
the need for it.
You know, I'm a reporter
I tend to look
at what's going on
today or yesterday.
I don't see anybody organizing
around healthcare today,
which I think is disappointing.
Even just the whole ACA battle
could use an Act Up to go
and try to bring some sense.
One of the things of that kind
of aggressive street activism
did was empower the good voices
in government and in pharma
and in research institutions.
It gave them power.
It gave Anthony Fauci, for example,
the ability to go to Congress
and say I need this money,
because look what's
happening in the streets.
So, there's a symbiosis that
worked then and could work again.
And I do believe that there's
that they laid out a blueprint
for how social justice activism can
be taken to any number of issues,
and certainly back to
healthcare again today.
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
And I think the book kind of bears
this out, but activism fails mostly.
And that you know, takes away
the spirit from a lot of people,
if you don't get immediate results.
But what Act Up showed us is that
if you, I mean Act Up was at it
for 10 years, it took them 10
years to you know, to rest the kind
of victory that they
were looking for.
And they just never stopped.
Every failure and every
disappointment they brought back
into those crowded meetings,
and discussed, and tore apart,
and debated, and they
re-strategized,
and went out again the
next day to try it again.
And I think so many of the recent
movements, the Occupy movement,
for example, that seemed
to gather strength all
across the country,
it didn't keep at it.
They didn't, you know,
they succumbed to failure.
And one wonders how a group
of people can overcome
that so thoroughly
the way Act Up did.
And Act Up was not just in New
York, there were 147 chapters
of the organization around
the world, 19 countries.
And they just kept going.
So, how do you find that?
How do you find the inspiration, or
the motivation to just keep going?
I don't know.
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
Of course, I think that's mostly
what I wrote about were the people
that I considered heroes.
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
Well, I think the other thing that
you can't not take into account
when you watch the
film or read the book,
there was no social media then.
And so, people had to be together.
They had to be the same room.
There had to be rooms with
people in those rooms.
And there's something about
that kind of gathering
that social media doesn't replicate.
And social media makes
it easy to reach people,
but we should be reaching people and
inviting them into rooms I think.
And in those rooms is
where ideas become grand.
Ambition becomes finally,
you know honed,
and yeah, get off social media.
I think that's the big
message I have for everybody,
except you should sign up to
my Facebook page [laugther].
Yes?
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
It has been, but you know, I think
one of those ancestors maybe.
But I think prep is a great idea.
And prep, which is pre-exposure
prophylaxis is why the numbers have
gone down from transmissions
over the last couple of years.
It's also why people stop
using condoms and why gonorrhea
and syphilis have gone
through the roof.
So, it's creating another problem.
But in fact, it could bring an end
to the epidemic, or participate
as one of the significant tools in
bringing an end to the epidemic.
Putting people on treatment,
we know people who are
on effective treatment
are not infectious.
Putting people who are at high risk,
these kids in the south on prep,
and that's where the virus is being
bounced around so dramatically.
That we could bring the numbers
down so low that it's you know,
no longer a steady state
you know of infections.
And it could work.
But you know, I frankly
don't know what's going on,
if anything in the area
of trying to cure HIV.
I think maybe that
needs to be jumpstarted.
I know that there's a
lot of profit to be made
in treating a disease
without curing it.
It's, exactly.
And then you increase the
marketplace by selling the same drug
and calling it prep, right?
So. It reminded me that the first
of the demonstrations that Act
Up brought to the NIH, it was
because in those first five, six,
seven years of the epidemic,
eight years of the epidemic,
the only research that was
being conducted was on HIV.
Or what was presumed to be
HIV in the earlier days.
But nobody was doing any research
on the opportunistic infections
which were what were
taking people's lives.
Nobody was doing research
on pneumocystis pneumonia.
on any of the diseases
that were the actual
proximate causes of death.
And they determined, the activists,
that it was because there was
no potential for a Nobel Prize
in being able to impact pneumonia.
So, the chant of the
demonstration at the NIH was
"Every four minutes someone
dies, fuck your Nobel Prize."
And their message was a
little on the sharp side,
but they really were exposing what
was a major issue in research,
that no one had prioritized
the opportunistic infections
and that no federal money, even by
1988, 1989 was going to the research
on any of the 23 OIs that
were killing people then.
Yeah?
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
The question is about stigma.
And it surprises me that we should
still have stigma around HIV.
But it is really a
structural problem.
It keeps people from getting tested.
And we still have, in many states
and in many parts of the world,
it's illegal for people with HIV
to have sex with other people.
Even if it's safe sex.
Even if your undetectable.
And you know, there are
people in jail today
who have not infected
anybody, but who simply had sex
with them under those laws.
So, the culture's not
dealing with it,
the politicians aren't
dealing with it.
And the only place you find
HIV stigma being discussed is
in HIV publications, where
people are already HIV positive.
And it's certainly one of
the factors that's keeping us
from reaching those
kids in the south.
And they really are kids.
And the epidemic is still
really a gay epidemic,
gay or transgender epidemic.
And there's still stigma around that
too, about being gay in the south,
and about being trans in the south.
And in America, and in the world.
So, there's much yet to be done.
That's it?
Thank you all for coming.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.